in this episode of XX files if the dogs
can detect between a healthy sample
versus a cancer sample then we want to
look at those samples oh yeah that one's
unpleasant that sounds like I'm gonna
put a star that smells like body odor
my name is Kate preggy and I am a
chemist here at the Monell chemical
senses Center I'm a postdoctoral fellow
in the lab dr. George credi and we study
human body odors it does get a lot of
giggles when I tell people what I work
on but there actually is a lot of
information that odors tell us about
human beings for example so I wanted to
use my chemical background and maybe
harness some of the power of odors and
learn what we can from them we found
that no two individuals smell the same
whether that's looking at your earwax
profile bottle profile or your body odor
profile so much in the same way you have
an individualized fingerprint so
identifiers you you in fact have an
individual odor prints we're interested
in seeing if we can get information
about what UV in containing your earwax
so we're gonna start here and we're
gonna get up a four sample of the ear
acts from our subject everyone's ear wax
is ghosts next isn't special and then
we're gonna go downstairs and have the
subjects eat in orange and be exposed to
the orange in the atmosphere for about
thirty minutes and then we take an after
sample we're looking to see is there a
change or an increase in limonene the
major chemical volatile chemical found
in orange so we understand we're not
going to get a lifetime of human
information but if you can get any type
of retention from your environment what
you've been exposed to there's a lot of
applications that we can envision once
we understand what types of chemicals
are produced by the human body we want
to know what happens when things change
or when you're when there's the disease
State for example and we've segue it
into studying disease seeds and what
that means on your overall odor profile
we're using a really interesting
multidisciplinary approach so it's been
shown that dogs can actually detect
cancer what we're doing is we're trying
to use dogs to help us determine what
volatile biomarkers are associated with
ovarian cancer my name's Jonathan ball
and I trained the medical alert dogs
here at the working dog Center I am
always amazed by the dogs in here it's
hard to appreciate you know how subtle
these odor differences are and we are
left with the dogs to kind of tease that
out and the dogs come to us the first
step is just introduce an introduction
to that odor that plasma with the
malignant cancer in it and then pairing
it with a food reward we're shaping that
sniff we'll do that for about a week and
then the next step is introduction to
the control or a normal plasma still
pairing that with a food reward and then
we move to the wheel we place both
samples in the wheel and the dog does
the same game at this time on the wheel
very similar to what you saw with Olin
when we have some reliability the dog is
consistently showing an interest in the
malignant then we'll start in spacing
them further apart when the dog clearly
gets the game between those two scents
will introduce the benign example
control these experiments are basically
running in parallel so the dogs are
being trained right now and actually if
the dogs can detect between healthy
sample versus a cancer sample then we
want to look at those samples and see
what are the chemicals that the dogs are
triggering to and which ones are
characteristic or biomarkers of disease
we're then taking the approach of using
we have a collaboration with a physicist
at the University of Pennsylvania
you can design nano devices that are
able to specifically detect volatile
chemicals and then we could have a
handheld device for example that could
be used in the clinic one day to
diagnose ovarian cancer at a much
earlier stage
I'm not sure exactly what the future
holds or what I'm going to do next but I
love the research that I'm involved in
now I love the application of it I would
love to be involved in research that
really has an impact on human health and
the overall well-being and whether
that's an industry or in academia or if
it's teaching a future generation of
scientists I'm hoping for great things
I study a group of scorpions that bond
to the genius centroid these commonly
known as the bark scorpions and they
make venom that is intensely painful
some people describe it as the feeling
or sensation of being burned with a
cigarette or being branded and that
could be followed by a sensation you
feel like somebody's hit you with a
hammer hopefully the weather will hold
could rain might be beautiful might not
rain we got over 100 last night it's
always a it's a gamble but